like he's trying to show me memories
seeking me once that when you say it
does this mean that's my dad right
there's a lot
when I do a reading I like to just kind
of get it all out whether it makes sense
or not I like to just verbalize
everything that I see here in the field
so anybody can technically come in and
as we kind of go through this sometimes
I'll hold on to an object and that'll
sometimes help kind of make a connection
so today do you bring the objects I did
okay do you mind if I hold onto it I
hope this isn't too gross number of
objects in my time it's an earring
fabulous so I'm just gonna communicate
everything that comes in and then we'll
go from there
okay everything this gift thing gift
gift it is again way this is coming
through this is kind of interesting
I haven't talked about the timing of a
situation and there's never a convenient
time to die but there's this whole
feeling of like passing and then
starting anew but they're like putting
the two around the same time and it's
kind of strange but basically like
symbolically this would basically refer
to an individual who experiences the
death of a loved one and then like right
after that there's something new or
something big that they kind of start in
their lives if I think of something do
you want me to tell you sure you can
verbalize II um yeah I mean I don't know
if this is it but well I mean I lost my
father died I was in college so and that
was a gift for my father I don't know if
it's I mean if it right after my dad
died he moved to Los Angeles and I
probably have a lot of regret of course
because I feel like I little bit he's
putting a positivity around it not a
negativity it's almost like this is an
exciting thing this is a positive thing
he's putting a very strong like
admiration around independence for you
for some reason just good to know Suzie
was independent but then for some reason
he's bringing the family along you know
in another level so it is possible
sometimes we'll see like one person
makes move and the men moving another
family member here or the rest of family
joins or something all those lines
there's wondering why you said three
because it's me and my brother and my
sister that's three of us and then my
little sister moved here but I think I
do I deal with like a lot of him the
oldest sibling and to make sure
everybody's happy I put a lot of
myself that works absolutely this is
kinda random and you know he's come to
terms he has a lot of peace when he
comes through about his history and it's
really interesting when he's having we
talk about like family history when you
see it does this mean that's my dad
right there's a figure which what I'm
gonna do first he was hit me with love
life I'm joking about love life and like
fun around that and then the other thing
is I'm we talked about like hospital
when you said history I wondered because
I had a lot of questions about what
exactly happened
gotcha and you know it's just hard to
have not have been a part of it at all
because I have a lot of confusion I've
always wondered like does he feel good
about those decisions really yes I wanna
you know when he comes through he's so
much more focused on his family than any
regret or anything that could have
should have what is and it's often true
when they come through they very rarely
are hung up on the past it's us you're
kind of left with yeah there are
situations and all of the difficulty
with that I'm trying to I don't know
what this is
he's basically just kind of
communicating this feeling of
frustration around something up here
it's kind of how I would describe it and
there's a feeling of like I'm free of
this I'm good I'm alright but this was
really clearly like it annoying thing do
you know what this is he couldn't talk
the same and communicate the same and he
was wearing I came back out of the time
and I think it it brought him a lot of
shame it was sort of hard and you know
looking back I wish that I
I just didn't know how sick he was and I
wish I'd been more sensitive about it so
those are all normal emotions the fact
that these things are coming up today or
his way of trying to release you of
these things a lot of this is really
just to let you know by his ability to
validate this he shows that he's free of
it that he's not stuck in a physical
state anymore he just is routing this in
protection and being protective from his
perspective this was all just to protect
in the long run I mean that's what they
my mom's reason was always like we
wanted to protect you guys from area I
need you to know when he comes across
there is this feeling of still trying to
communicate in other ways there is this
feeling of communicating
in some way and Saturday for someone
hold his hand and squeezed it okay I'm
always like like I think about the
feeling in his hands that you know there
are no accidents what comes through
there are no accidents with this and you
need to know that he appreciates that
because that is a form of communication
and another you know are there any
questions that you feel mom family
anybody could have to help kind of
provide more resolution just if you
would have a message for my mom or my
sister my brother is anything you
wouldn't want them to know do you know
of anyone who goes by their initials
like JJ TJ a DJ I was my brother's my
dad used to call my brother JD JD okay
gotcha
the reason why I mentioned this because
they're acknowledging this individual
initial emotions like I have to say
hello can't forget you for some reason
he's connecting himself to your brother
in kind of a more tangible sense and so
like he might end up getting gifted like
a wallet or a watch or like something he
would carry with him but for some reason
he's putting it on his body in some way
just remember that I'm saying it because
he's like when you have this I'm with
him and it's very rude rather like just
started wearing his clothes there you go
when he does this he'll know that he's
with him and he's gonna continue to be
and of all of these people of all of
your family living in past there's such
a pride around you for you being able to
just keep going and be there not only
for yourself but for your whole family
that's not easy so give yourself a pat
on the back and know that dad's proud of
you
oh my gosh this is so much
[Music]